dans son bac de récupération évident
mais tout ce qu'elle peut pour elle
c'est un geste important
on veut faire notre part on veut que et
on veut aider pour la planète ont vu que
nos enfants aient un meilleur avenir
l'an passé les québécois comme evelyne
ont envoyé près de 2 millions de tonnes
de matières dans les centres de tri je
trouve que la récupération donne la
valeur aux choses en fait parce que les
choses sont pas jetable les choses
peuvent être ils peuvent être
utilisables selon recyc-québec en 2018
près de 200 mille tonnes 20 % des
matières envoyées dans les centres de
tri n'ont pas été recyclés elles ont été
rejetées envoyés dans des sites
d'enfouissement
beaucoup de déchet mais aussi des
matières recyclables
moi je trouve ça très chacun c'est comme
une trahison en fait je trouve parce que
c'est comme si on fait pas le
les farc ont fait paul maury le taux de
rejet dans les centres de tri augmenté
de 25% l'an passé chez recyc québec on
attribue cette hausse à la situation
difficile qui frappe l'industrie avec la
fermeture de certains marchés
d'exportation les exigences déjà des
acheteurs ont augmenté donc les centres
de tri font de plus en plus attention à
limiter au maximum la contamination dans
leurs ballots la situation est telle
dans l'est du strict que des centres de
tri sont pris avec qu'ils mille tonnes
de matières des ballots qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à écouler sur les marchés
notamment des ballots de saké pellicule
donc c'est une matière qui pour lesquels
il ya très peu et n'ont quasiment aucun
débouché présentement le problème du
recyclage du verre reste entier au
québec l'an dernier 78 mille tonnes
devait récupérer ont été envoyés dans
les sites d'enfouissement en 2010 au
niveau du verre il ya 28 % qui était
qui vient des résidences qui était
recyclé donc on a un défi d'augmenter le
taux de recyclage de cette matière là
mais les choses pourraient changer si le
gouvernement du québec élargi la
consigne aux bouteilles de vins et de
spiritueux et si jean-philippe robien à
radio canada montréal